will be wrecked right now that's how
quickly we're back hey we have a a green
room that people hang out in before they
come here and that green room has been
remodeled it looks fantastic so the
sponsors of this segment in style
furniture
did the job for us and we're going to
give you a look right now and they
sponsored this segment
welcome to las vegas now's newly
remodeled green room i am brooke fritz i
am an interior designer as well as a
vent designer we have partnered up with
in-style furniture to bring this look to
you
in style furniture has a huge warehouse
for us to choose from so we wanted to
have a pop of color in this room
something fun for our guests to enjoy
but we also wanted it to be very
comfortable so we ended up going with
these really soft teal couches
and then we accented it with these fun
furry acrylic
accentures accentures along with a
coffee table that's gold and acrylic as
well we also have a highboy table in the
back
corner accented with some leather
barstool chairs that that's fun for our
guests to sit in we also have this bar
over here that we have accented with
candy because las vegas now is a fun
youthful vibe and we wanted our guests
to feel
that same vibe as they come here so we
filled it with colorful candy for them
to enjoy a great way to revitalize your
space is a fresh coat of paint we used
blue ape painting dot com all the walls
in this room we painted white we painted
a fresh coat of white but we wanted an
accent wall that popped so with our
white walls we chose a dark wall with
accent
wood design on it and of course las
vegas is all about the neon sign right
so las vegas now had to have a neon sign
to represent who we are this project has
been so much fun to do with las vegas
now as well as in style furniture their
staff is amazing and when you go to
their warehouse there is so much to
choose from and if you feel overwhelmed
their staff will help you pick out the
design look you're going for within
style furniture we also had the pleasure
of designing one of the sets for las
vegas now so within studio b it feels
like a home so we wanted to go with
neutral colors with accents of things
that you would find in your home like
books and platters and greenery and so
within style we were able to create that
look so between the green room and the
set
with in style furniture we were able to
create a comfortable yet modern look
and it was such a joy to work with in
style and las vegas now as clover and
stem to create this area
we love it looks great it's definitely
an upgrade and we've upgraded the snacks
too have you guys noticed that used to
be just stale pretzels and now we
actually have fresh snacks thank you to
in-style furniture superstore for
sponsoring this segment and for our new
green room you can learn more about them
by giving them a phone call at
702-636-9458 or you can use that world
wide web and go to
instylefurnitureinc.com they have a
special offer free same day local
delivery and set up if scheduling
permits
more